it looks like
uh
cordial like just
yeah some
weird flavored cordial
[Music]
at first i thought these instagram
photos will photoshop but no it turns
out australia has pink lakes water's
clear or blue or green sometimes brown
so why are they pink and why does it
happen so much in australia australia is
home to hundreds of ephemeral pink lakes
a permanent one is lake hillier in
western australia i'll admit it looks
fake
it's certainly not fake no
and it is that pink in person i've been
there i've seen it it is quite
phenomenal to look at it's like a pink
milkshake did you drink it wouldn't
recommend drinking it in fact lake helia
is 10 times saltier than the ocean sea
water is in 2015 ken visited lake
hillier to try and solve the pink
mystery a lot of people knew that there
was a certain algae in these salt lakes
called denaliella and so the theory was
that that was going to be the cause of
the pinkness denali ella selena thrives
in super salty water
as the environment in the lake gets more
and more extreme this d selena
starts pumping out as much pigment into
its cells to protect it from the uv
the pigment is called beta carotene
which also gives red cabbage and carrots
their color
eventually up to 16 percent of the dry
weight of that of that cell can be
filled full of bambita carotene so
the more it gets in there the more red
it is so you tested lake hilly as water
but you discovered something unexpected
we confirmed that denali selena the
algae was there but it was there in low
amounts and really one thing stood out
to us and that was this bacteria called
celinobacteruba and that bacteria is
this pinkish red color so is this
bacteria why lake hilliar's color is so
bright that's more vibrant because the
actual bacteria can contain more of the
pigment there's no other chloroplast to
contain it it's just these bacteria
cells just fill themselves up with the
help of these critters lake hilliar has
been pink for centuries but not every
pink plate keeps its color this is the
same lake as what i saw before get out
of town no well it's not pink it's no
longer pink why it lost its pinkness
sure lake hilliar is popular now
but in the 80s it was pink lake that got
the people excited yeah the pink lake
driving pink lake road pink lake
butchers and all these commercial
businesses and places named after pink
lake and and the lake hasn't been pink
since late 1990s pink lake lost its hue
due to excessive salt harvesting telo
estimates it would take five to ten
years of intervention to make it pink
again tilo how come you're in your car
man is everything all right esperanza's
internet is uh
is pretty interesting at the best of
times i've gone to the source so that's
why i'm in my car parked under a
i am 4g 5g tower
while wa's lakes look like
i know strawberry milk this one in the
heart of melbourne looks like toxic
runoff
hi marty so this lake
it can't seem to make up its mind it's
dark green on google earth but it's been
pink in the past it's since 2012 it has
been pink at times um so the last time
it went pink was april 2019
we just haven't seen it return since
with the coolest summers we have had a
spell of dry hot weather will change the
salt levels in the lake it is a natural
phenomenon that happens when the the
temperatures are right um drying out the
um evaporating the fresh water element
out of the salt water um that then
activates the the algaes which then give
it the pink appearance there's a dead
giveaway when these aquatic changes
occur there is sort of a two-week period
where uh the the nose of our ranges
can um tell us whether it's going to
change or whether it's about to change
there is a lovely
aroma in the air
uh
that gives us that hint that yeah
something's changing in the water it's
it's close to spoiled eggs
gross
have you been tempted to swim in it
yourself no i i can't say i have been
it's a sight to be seen and
that's as far as i'm happy to go how
come australia has so many salt lakes
the combination about climate hydrology
hydro geology australia is a very old
continent underneath those lakes sit
saline water tables
and
with that that drying climate and that
that stable hydrology for millions of
years the evolution has just occurred so
that these make sense for these um
these little algae or bacteria to
protect themselves from the harsh
ultraviolet light honestly there would
be hundreds of pink salt lakes in west
australia are lying
[Music]
you